thank you for being uh with us mr
mcdonald so
we just heard from kierstarma who said
that he would like to see all
schools open to all pupils from the 8th
of march now of course that's not what
the teaching unions are saying
who do you think is right in this debate
well the teaching unions are saying very
similar to kier that
of course we want the schools to open
but it's got to be safe
and i can't think of anyone better to
listen to
than those on the front line and dara is
the teachers unions it's interesting
i don't think this has happened very
often but all the teachers union
including those who
represent the head teachers and school
leaders as well as the
frontline teaching staff themselves all
saying the same thing
so i think listen to the unions and i
don't think that's different from what
kiara is saying kira is saying is when
it's safe and
if we have to have a staggered reopening
of the schools
let's listen to those on the front line
okay you're also calling today
for a lot of the debts built up during
the pandemic to be
cancelled so how much debt are we
talking about and how would you pay for
it
well at the moment what we're finding is
well look at the figures that have come
out this morning we've now got nearly
half a million people
not just living in poverty but in
destitution
and if you look at what's coming from
the citizens advice bureau and the
the debt campaigning organization step
change we have now
about a million well just over a million
in severe debt
someone said the one of the calculations
from step change was
there's about a 10 billion pound debt
that's been caused by coving
on individuals and families themselves
it's a fair amount of money
but even if we just made a start on that
let's take this six hundred thousand who
are behind with their rents and
their mortgages we're talking about a
billion pounds worth that's needed
to take that pressure off them and the
way that you do that
is well you know we lifted the debt off
the banks when the banks were in crisis
hundreds of billions were lifted off
them by taking the debt over by the bank
of england and therefore
service that much more cheaply but
actually if you did want to pay for it
in one fell swoop
why not have a windfall tax on those
companies in the well the banks and the
property developers
tech companies and others maybe some of
those
cronies have had contracts during the
covid crisis as well
why not a windfall tax on them to lift
the debt off the poorest and you know
one in five of those in serious debt are
key workers the very people are getting
us through this pandemic
so i think it's one of those policies
that's readily available in fact
you know boris johnson and others have
referred back to the period after the
second world war
rad butler as a conservative chancellor
in 51
actually introduced a windfall tax on
those companies that made vast profits
during the war and post-war period so
it's something that's been done
time and time again i also note that
you've said today
there's a time for framing speeches and
political positioning
but there is also a time to get angry
and demand amnesia action to help
people survive who exactly is that
message meant for
for all of us for all of us here today
framing speech during the week where he
for me you know basically saying we need
to be as radical as the
atlea government and we need to tackle
inequality as our main
central thrust of policy that suits me
fine
what we need to do now is roll that out
and i think all of us both
towards the labor front base labour and
peace all those progressives actually
commentators as well i think need to get
serious with holding this government to
account
and actually i am i am angry people are
suffering you know
people those in debt but also those who
are struggling to get to work have had
their wages cut
and i am angry my constituents have been
treated badly during this pandemic only
two miles down the road from here i have
heathrow limited a company that is now
doing fire and higher sacking people and
then only re-employing them when they
cut their wages
outlawing fire and rehire as a policy i
think is something
we should all be arguing for now and yes
i am angry about why
people are living in poverty you know a
lot of those people on the front line
who are trying to get us through this
pandemic some of them are having to live
off food banks that's unacceptable
and yet this government is now growing
flicked upon many of them
another pay freeze so yeah there's a lot
to be angry about and i think we need to
hold this government to account i'm glad
i'm glad you asked hancock about the con
contracts i wish you had gone further
and asked him is it a requirement to do
donate to the tory party to get one of
these contracts because that's what it
appears to be at the moment
because this vip route for these
contracts so yes i think people should
get angry
and should start demanding
accountability from this government
and demanding change do you think that
kier stamos should get a bit angry then
i think we're now moving into the phase
where yes
i don't think it's just on kei's
shoulders i think it's for all of us all
of us who care about our community
whether you're a politician or a member
of the community or yes journalists as
well it's time to hold this government
to account
120 000 dead you know food banks now
having to support so many people
homelessness rising again
we've got a situation where we're now
for a budget we've only just heard the
furlough be extended that decision
should have been made months ago the
government looks as though it's going to
hold on to
the 20 pound increase in universal
credit yet living off universal credit
is thrusting people into
well destitution as we've seen and the
figures today
we need action from this government we
need to hold it to account and yes we
need to be putting forward alternatives
now
we can't wait until the next election we
need to be bringing forward the policies
that can
provide people with hope and a vision of
a better society
kir's speech during the week framed this
debate
now we've got to drive it forward um
do you think that people who voted for
kirsten in the leadership election
thinking that he would continue on some
of the radical policies under yourself
and jeremy corbyn
may have been a bit disappointed
well look i took the view and jeremy did
the same is that when we stood down
jeremy's leader sherry charles we would
not
treat the incoming leadership in the way
that we were treated
carping from the sidelines et cetera
what we said we'd do is that
we would support them all we could and
we have done that
and now what we want to do is support
them in the rollout of
a radical policy program the ways in
which we hold the
well hold this government to account in
the way in which we can present an
alternative
to this government but what i'm saying
is you can't leave that until so close
to the next election
if if we've learned anything you need to
present that vision but then
start presenting the details that will
enable us to achieve that vision
and that does mean starting early rather
than leaving it too late because you've
got to
win the argument can i also say just one
word of advice as
which you and jeremy corbyn failed to do
winning an election
well the way if you want to learn
anything from us
we had an early election thrust upon us
in many
ways we lost the opportunity of bedding
down and winning the argument
over the vision of the society we want
to create all the individual policies
you need to start early
and that's what i'm saying let's get on
with that now let's really now
hold this government to account let's
really now set out
that clear vision exactly as kate did
during the week that
radicalness of the athlete government
tackling inequality but let's start
talking about the alternative program
the detail of those policies i have to
say also my only
real word of advice to kyra is well
let's unite the party as he promised and
that does mean
you know giving the whip back to jeremy
corbyn let's unite the party so we can
move on
and really be an effective opposition
holding this government to account but
presenting an alternative
and also the way we are at the moment
doing everything we can to support those
people
who are suffering so much under this
government okay
uh john mcdonald thank you very much for
being on the programme this morning
thank you